حتى من مسافة بعيدة، فإن الدمار الذي
يحدث في غزة
لا لبس فيه، فنحن هنا على بعد بضع مئات من الأمتار
من الحدود مع غزة، ولكن
حتى هنا يمكنك الشعور بدرجة
القصف الإسرائيلي لغزة،
والكثافة الهائلة
والحجم، وهذا هو ما يبدو عليه الأمر.
أصبحت مشاهد الدمار القريبة
مألوفة للغاية هنا، في أعقاب
غارة جوية إسرائيلية أخرى هذه المرة في أواخر
أكتوبر/تشرين الأول على مخيم جباليا للاجئين، وهو
أحد أكثر
المناطق السكنية اكتظاظا بالسكان في غزة، والقنبلة التي
تسببت في هذا الضرر هي قنبلة من 2000 قنبلة
مصنوعة على الأرجح.  في الولايات المتحدة، أسقطتها
القوات الجوية الإسرائيلية بما لا يقل عن أربعة أضعاف
قوة
القنابل التي استخدمتها الولايات المتحدة في حربها
ضد
داعش في قطاع غزة المكتظ بالسكان، فإن
التكلفة البشرية لا تضاهى، حيث تم القضاء على عائلات بأكملها
في
مخيم جباليا للاجئين.  أحد
بؤر حملة القصف الإسرائيلية
لفهم الصورة الكاملة
وحجم الدمار في غزة،
عليك أن تنظر من
الأعلى بالتنسيق مع شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
حيث
تمكنت شبكة CNN من تحديد موقع أكثر من 100 صندوق
خلفها القصف في عام 2013 فقط.  في
الشهر الأول من الحرب باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي، قمنا بتحليل
قطر هذه الحفر، أكثر من 500
منها كان قطرها أكبر من 40 قدمًا
بما يتوافق مع
2000 قنبلة أمريكية الصنع استخدمتها القوات الجوية الإسرائيلية،
ويغطي تحليلنا فترة شهر واحد
حتى 6 نوفمبر حيث
يُعتقد أن 10.000 شخص قد
لقوا حتفهم، وقد أدلى أكبر
دبلوماسي أمريكي في الشرق الأوسط بشهادته في
9 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر)، وقد يكون عدد القتلى
أعلى في هذه الفترة من
الصراع وظروف الحرب،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية بالنسبة لأي منا
لتقييم معدل
الضحايا، نعتقد أنه
مرتفع جدًا بصراحة، وربما يكون
أعلى مما يتم
الاستشهاد به، ومع ذلك تستمر الولايات المتحدة في دعم
القصف الإسرائيلي، فلماذا يكون الموت
مذهلًا جدًا لأنه  لا
يتعلق الأمر فقط بنقطة التأثير، فهذه حفرة
ناجمة عن قنبلة تزن 2000 رطل،
يمكن لمنطقة القتل المحتملة من تلك الحفرة أن تنتشر
حتى 365 مترًا، أي 1200 قدم، وهي مساحة
تعادل حوالي 60 ملعبًا لكرة القدم
أو حوالي 90 ملعبًا لكرة القدم الأمريكية، حسبما
قال الجيش الإسرائيلي.  تتناقض شبكة سي إن إن في سانت لويس
مع هجمات حماس المتعمدة على
الرجال والنساء والأطفال الإسرائيليين، حيث
تتبع مؤسسة إيدا القانون الدولي وتتخذ
الاحتياطات الممكنة للتخفيف من
الأضرار التي تلحق بالمدنيين، ولكن هل هذا صحيح؟ هذا يقع
شمال مخيم الشاطئ للاجئين
على طول الطريق الساحلي الرئيسي عندما
تقترب منه.  يمكنك أن ترى في هذا الحي الصغير فقط
ما لا يقل عن تسعة كيتس
تتوافق مع 2000 قنبلة شريطية مما
يعني أن منطقة القتل المحتملة يمكن أن
تشمل هذه المنطقة بأكملها، يُظهر تحليل CNN والمواد
الاصطناعية للدمار الذي لحق
بغزة قصفًا واسع النطاق
في منطقة مكتظة بالسكان
واستخدام هذه القنابل  إنها
عشوائية بطبيعتها، ولا تزال التكلفة البشرية تؤذي ما
يقرب من 20 ألف شخص، ولا يزال العديد من
الموتى غير مدفونين تحت
الأنقاض دون نهاية في
الأفق.